und urlauber sascha aus frankfurt sitzt
seit mehreren wochen in der westsahara
fest wenn gruner herrscht eine strenge
ausgangssperren maximal einmal pro woche
darf ein kleiner teil der urlauber
begleitet vom militär wohlgemerkt in den
nächsten ort und sascha ist mir jetzt
auch zugeschaltet wo sind sie denn
gerade einen schönen guten abend nach
deutschland ich befinde mich gerade in
agadir
ich bin jetzt von tag hochgefahren mit
einem extra papier vom bahnhof fahren
darf durch reisegenehmigung befinde mich
gerade agadir und warte gerade auf den
anrufern der fährgesellschaft um dann
ihr dementsprechend mit der sommer wäre
am 18 juli ausreisen zu können
vielleicht können jetzt mal sage noch
mal sagen wie lange sitzen sie jetzt
schon wegen corona dort fest
also wir müssen nur auf coroner beziehe
ich bin jetzt gerade schon sieben monate
hier ich wollte ein ich habe 18 märz
ausreisen und die fähre wurde gecancelt
mittlerweile 70-jährigen corona ungefähr
drei monate fest was macht man die ganze
zeit wenn man dort festsetzt das ist das
eine sehr gute frage also ich hab das
drücke ich kann von unterwegs aus
arbeiten deswegen habe ich relativ viel
gearbeitet um später haben wir dann in
offiziell die genehmigung bekommen wir
ein bisschen kitesurfen zu dürfen mal
die stimmung ein bisschen gekippt ist
aber ansonsten essen trinken arbeiten
also ein recht eingeschränkte alter
wie kann man so aber nicht machen jetzt
haben auch ihren hund gesehen ich habe
da gibt es auch eine traurige geschichte
zu ja mein hund man übrigens der auch
wenn er jetzt gerade woanders ist und da
ist ein anderer sprecher
auf der reise hin sagt gestorben und
dann musste ich leider dort
er hat liegen aber mit einem sehr sehr
schönen blick auf die lagune und er hat
einen ganz ganz schönen platz mehr
bekommen
es tut mir ziemlich weh aber so ist nun
mal das leben und wir alle müssen
irgendwann gehen das heißt er und war
mit ihnen im urlaub er ist immer bei mir
über wo ich hingefahren
immer mit dabei und jetzt so seine
gedanken bei mir haben sie sich denn im
stich gelassen gefühlt von der deutschen
bundesregierung
das könnte man so direkt nicht sagen
dass denkmals wurde ein bisschen zu
wenig getan
das hauptproblem lag er daran dass hier
keine fähren anlegen durften und dass
die fährgesellschaft gmv tickets
verkauft hat für mehr verbindungen
stattfinden dürfen
ob die bundesregierung daran schuld dass
mag ich nicht einzuschätzen die deutsche
botschaft hier und der kulturtag rotoren
setzten sich 1 1 und haben bis auch
diese sonder fähre zusammen mit rollen
dann auf die beine gestellt ehre wem
ehre gebührt also das muss ich auf jeden
fall mal ganz klar sagen und was machen
sie als erstes wenn sie dann wieder zu
hause sind ja erst mal freunde in die
arme schließen und garmisch dies mit
chronisten bisschen schwieriger erst mal
geholt erst machen selbstverständlich
davon aus weil ich so ein bisschen im
wechsel war dass ich kein krone habe
aber ein test kann ja nicht schaden
vorsorge ist immer ein bisschen besser
und dann ja freunde in die arme
schließen und das ist gerade das
schönste was ich mir das eigentlich nur
freunden und familie schön drücken wir
die daumen dass sie ganz schnell und
sicher nach hause kommen